[Music]
welcome to another lesson on psychology
today I have a game of carrots and
hopefully a taro come prepared for you
but before this starts I'd like to take
two seconds and share my condolences to
the chest society and dear LaVon our
onion for the passing of his wife
Mariana very sorry for that I knew her
very very little I only met her a few
times and San Luis but she was really
amazing very full of life I'm yeah I'm
very sad about it
I'm I can't even imagine how it's how it
is for her family and friends rest in
peace and just a few seconds of silence
please
okay well let's start our lesson so well
from last week I talked about how to
play against some of the openings
because I want you all to have the
chance to be as prepared as possible for
when you play games so one of the things
that I really liked was to prepare
here's my game my opponents I still
tried to do that and so last week we
showed the game of car Oakland with 97
against shocker shop and that game was
very nice and it was inevitable
tournaments I think it was 2015 yep yeah
2015 was my golden year so I'm going to
show you a game Pyrrhic which I played
in the same tournaments different
opponents and this was also about 200
rating higher than me so yeah I'm gonna
show you what I play that my thought
process doing since I can't see your
questions I'm gonna suggest to take a
minute to tank or so and feel free to
pause whatever so this is a very common
way to start off playing Park and so
basically I'm a big fan of playing f4
here and then the idea is to develop the
knight from f3
so next move you want to play Knight f3
Bishop d3 short castle and eventually e5
or 5
very nice setup I like that I have so
much space and it's the setup really
does make sense to me however for this
specific game I wanted to try something
different and so I played this Bishop
III so the idea is that playing Bishop
III I am going to try and form long
castle and so for example if the
opponent was to play Knight f6 I would
simply play let's say Queen d2 if for
example cast oh I can play f3 and next
move I'm going to try and play long cast
all followed by g4 and it seems like a
very pleasant setup however my opponents
instead of castle played 94 so I did
remember my preparation because I had
looked at this line deeply so I knew
that I was going to make them move that
I did in the game but I would like for
you to take a few seconds pause this
video and think what do you want to do
as white do you want to just ignore the
threat or do you want to move the bishop
so welcome back I decided to move the
bishop and Bishop g5 is the nice move
mainly because after f6 you get the
SPECIAL h4 + f6 is a little honestly
weird to do because castle is kind of
more logical but also this Knight here
is a little easy to attack so as white
you can simply cast all over here and
next
you can go for a ch3 g4 or f3 g4 so yeah
that seems to be what's wrong with y94
isn't the most precise move and so my
opponent plays f6 Bishop h4 so now I
would suggest to take a few seconds and
think about what's black can do because
you see black's pawn structure is well
kind of weird to be honest and so black
is it's highly unlikely for black to
make lanka a short cast up because let's
say for example short castle now first
of all I have this chick and after it
let's say you move your king now I can
start attacking your knight and now I
might have g4 or f4 and it's just
White's pieces are all in their best
positions whereas blacks pieces are all
this super disorganized so my opponent
decided to play e5 here so now I had to
make a decision do I want to exchange
these pawns go to an end game where my
pieces are placed better but I'm I
really like to have my Queens on the
court because it just gives me more
chances to kind of play tricky or to tie
my upon his hands basically so ya think
for yourself what would you want to do
do you want to take the pawn and go for
that endgame or you would come up with
some intermediate school for example so
in the game I did take the pawn but
another thing that I consider it was to
play 8th Street because if 96 I can just
simply play long castle and if I was
really just practices are extremely
misplaced one thing that I didn't like
was if black also played this
intermediate take and I have to take I
was a little uncertain about something
like knight c6 or even 95 white position
is is still better but I wanted to avoid
complications and so I took this pawn
taking back with Knight is not the best
option just simply because there is four
and then what do you want to do with
your Knights you move tonight there is
this Bishop c4 long castle it's a
everything works out for whites pretty
smoothly so my opponents David kevorkian
yeah took back with the D pawn and now I
decided to exchange the Queen's off and
do long castle with check now black has
a few options Bishop d7 9797 is the most
accurate one just because if Bishop d7
for example with Bishop d7 there is this
Bishop c4 the possibility of Bishop c4
coming up Bishop e6 and now you have to
move your king again what's a king c8 or
so and why just has very easy
development whereas after 97 Bishop c4
is still valid but it doesn't really
serve the same threats now black can
simply play c6 and the king is trying to
run away from here again white position
is still more pleasant and probably
still better yes it is still better but
yeah so what I decided to do was to
simply attack the knight and force
tonight to either move or the pawn
structure to change so the two logical
responses for black or 96 and h5 which
one would you do that's black or as
white which one would you prefer your
opponents to play well my opponents
point h5 and I really liked it because
it gave me the chance to keep attacking
this Knight and now I have a quite
beautiful move who says and games you
can't sacrifice so it should be very
nice if you could find this move on your
own but cause the game think a minute or
so and so okay for those of you who
found it - congratulation f4 is the move
that I played and the idea is very
simple when you take it I'm gonna simply
play Knight f3 and now my knight has
this Knights route whereas where the
four f4 if I plays Knight to f3 I don't
really have this night before anymore
just
and black can simply try and bring this
lights to d6 and everything is getting a
little bit controlled but after f4
athelets they take 9 f 3 9 f 7 doesn't
really work anymore
can someone well can can you guys think
why doesn't it work anymore
the answer is because of a 5 you see
this light is pinned so can't move this
pawn is pinned can't smooth and nice
can't take it just because I take back
and the only viable option would be to
consider something like g5 and now I
have so many winnable options I have 6 I
have he takes f6 let's say he takes up 6
let's say the bishop takes back I have a
95 now if you take over here I simply
take over here 96 and this is a very
pleasant position I'm like it should be
a decisive advantage I can even simply
just bring the knight back the biggest
problem with blacks position is that
black can't really develop the Queen
side let's say you touch this Knight
I just take this guy back or I just take
h4 and next move I'm coming to g6 and
all these pawns are falling
so that is why 9 f7 isn't the most
accurate smooth but it's really hard to
find a good move for black right now so
after Knight f3
I think g5 was probably the best move
but the problem with g5 is that there
might be dis sacrifices because now the
king is forced to go to e8
and now I get my d5 going after c7 let's
say you try to defend with Bishop e5 I
could simply take over here give you
check and this seems to be too good to
be true
honestly but now I have clear advantage
because I have three pawns against one
of your Knights and the problem is that
your pieces your queen sized pieces are
not getting outs so but I still think g5
would be the way to go
like if I was black I would probably
just play g5 because my opponents might
not take it that might just play like
fish of f2 let's say C 694 see why this
is still better but black is still
fighting and trying whereas just
compared this position to this position
White has a clear plan just attacking
everything so anywho my opponent decided
to play c6 now with everything that
we've seen so far the analysis that's
done what do you think the rights move
is hint what was wrong with Knight f7
yep for those of you who found it and
the ones who just thought about it great
their rights moments to play e5 so the
idea is very simple
basically with E 5 you want to just take
over here or play a 6 and well taking
back isn't an option because this is
pinned the knight is pinned and let's
say for example if you were to play
Knight at 5 I could simply play g6
and this might fall fall because if you
take on h4 for example it doesn't help
the Mantis is still pent if you let's
say please g5 for example still no help
I can simply take over here so the only
move that wouldn't lose the piece is to
actually move the kingdom way for black
and so that's would be king c7 now II 6
is not accurate anymore simply because
95 you would be letting your opponent to
centralize his pieces and to start
developing and threatening your pieces
basically you would give your opponent's
too much game which I always recommend
against so the idea is that one of the
biggest things that over the years I
learned and I try to apply and every
situation in chess and sometime in real
life is to always be ahead of it one
always be ahead of the ideas always have
better ideas better spatial advantage
for example in this position and two in
order to achieve what you want in order
to win this game you need to find the
most accurate moves which also sometimes
they can be practical sometimes you
might miss a brilliant tactical idea
that the computer finds that's perfectly
fine
but in order to try and avoid those you
should have a good calculation but at
the same time if you're analyzing a line
that's giving your opponent's too much
room to breathe too much too much
compensation you should if you have
another option
you should probably look at that because
when your opponent has too much chances
too much options too much compensation
it will be really really hard for you to
find the only accurate moves just
talking from experience so here I didn't
want to play something like e six to
give my opponents the chance to take
over the center so what I did was I just
simply took over here on f6 let's say
Knight takes f6
and now this was also a pretty pretty
cute to be honest the way I thought
about it who is to try and improve the
pieces that are doing absolutely nothing
so this fight on f3 is doing something
just like on c3 is still doing something
so the two pieces that I considered
moving was Bishop this Bishop of each
you to maybe d3 to put some pressure
over here which probably would have been
met by for example Bishop a5 and the
other idea was to put this Bishop to g5
because my bishop on h4 is doing
absolutely nothing to just attacking f6
isn't as real threat and if my bishop
were to get to this diagonal then black
king is extremely weak and this would
increase my chances of winning this game
and so I played Bishop g5 and there
there is no realistic way to try and
keep this f4 pawn right so once my
opponents did was he just tried to play
Bishop a5 and just develop as much as he
can which in that situation probably is
the best option because another option
to think about was for example to try
and push this pawn and see like creates
room for the king two breeds probably
but let's say after take King d6
even Bishop III check you go away with
the King I really like this Knights to
move for this Bishop yeah this is clear
advantage fun fact for those of you who
like to solve mates
this is mating 6 so you can take a
second and find it so the way it goes is
with 36 I can you see seven up here and
before this is already pretty much mates
let's say you play g5 I simply take it
you try to survive it let's say anything
check and mate
same idea applies if you play King j7
because I gave the same night if I check
every reach the same position so yeah
for those of you who like to find nice
mates there is it anyways so my opponent
didn't play five and he played Bishop a5
simply take it now this is clearly
decisive advantage for white but how can
you actually win it because that's
something that a lot of players have
trouble I certainly have had and still
struggle with it because we're just
looking at the position I know I'm
better but how much better and also I
know that I know that I'm better but how
to actually convert the advantage to a
win is one of the big questions that I
have been working to understand better
and so yeah if you have any suggestions
ideas write in the comments I'll do my
best to read most or all of it later on
so
[Music]
yeah think about what would white wants
to do in this position so you're white
you know you have advantage what do you
do what I did in the game was I played
Knight e5 my idea was pretty simple I
just wanted to try and get here and so
my opponent stopped this from happening
now there is a very very nice tactical
idea I would recommend you guys to find
this or at least try to find it so again
this is winning for white but how to
actually get the point
so the things you should think about our
checks and takes the only check that you
have is drug the eight which is you
should immediately eliminated some of
the takes that you have is taking on g6
probably taking on c6 may be taking over
here well you can easily eliminate
visual age five and ninety six is they
don't serve any real purpose but ninety
six that actually does serve purpose why
because you your pawns can't take it
should be six and next game please so
this is not we wanna this is not the
simplest take but it is easy and you
should be able to find it just you have
to look for it and if you automatically
dismiss checks and takes and like start
trying to reorganize your pieces then
you are not going to see this so I
always emphasize I'm thinking about
checks and takes and lose the threats so
that you don't miss moves like this so
after taking c6 the game is very close
to ending but my opponents managed to
keep playing for another 15 moves so
he tries to well my strength is also
super simple if it's my moving in 97 and
well it's meat so the move is very
simple you kind of have to cover this
square up now I don't need to move my
Knights because you still can't take it
due to Bishop h6 checkmate so what I
could do is to bring this rook out
because this is my last piece that's not
doing anything right
so Ricky one basics now my opponent
wants to take it because let's say if I
do something weird he can take it right
there is no more Bishop a6 surprisingly
this is still playable not winning
anymore but surprisingly anyways back to
real chess so yeah think about where
does your Knights belong where could it
serve a good purpose I thought a lot
about some lines a5 doing the game just
because I wanted to go after this pawn
but I also really really wanted to keep
my knight in the center because it's it
felt like it's serving a nice purpose
it's blocking this this Bishop it's
attacking this pawn I'm looking at this
d7 Square and this 94-96 might be coming
up so it felt like a nice idea at the
time which was a good move
my opponents try to play Bishop h6 to
exchange some pieces off and now I got
this I'm just looking at the game just
looking at the board before making a
decision on if you should exchange this
what should the exchange so one of the
things that I really like to try and I'm
working on and I'm improving its the
exchanges so for example over here I do
have to take it but maybe rook F 1 is
also worth considering I honestly didn't
considerate that deep in the game just
because I I just wanted I'm a material
up I wanted to exchange the bishop and
the exchange in the bishop would put
this 3/8 knight back into each six
useless h6 but just thinking about this
right now this jerk on f4 is much more
productive
Brooksie for coming up.maybe d4 doubling
it up a lot of ideas but after taking on
h6 Knight takes so what I did was I
applied Bishop d3 mainly because I
wanted to go after the pawns let's say
we create ooh this is a nice yeah take a
few second and think about this move and
[Music]
yeah this is very nice it's very kind of
neat yeah
so what I did was to simply play at
night c4 I just want to come take your
pieces for example for p8
this is super winning but how take well
what one thing that I could have done
was to take over here and then just play
your freaky 6c I'm kind of suffocating
my opponent the King is kind of doesn't
really have anywhere but c7 to go all of
the pieces are wobbly actually where do
you want to place your knight can you
even move the slide because if you move
this night I just have 95 right yeah and
this is really losing so it's losing
mainly because okay first ill Knight b6
is coming there is g-force right to the
night or even g4 here should to be
getting the job done
yeah so I decided to just play 96 and to
[Music]
improve my position like this so my idea
was well you were not gonna play King b6
cuz of well check and if you simply go
back to c8 rook on the seventh rank we
all heard about that rook slap second
ranks for seven strings so I could
simply just put more pressure and win
this piece so the problem is you can't
really move the Knights right because if
you let's say move the knight I'm gonna
go for the kill
and if he tries to defend it
it gets pain then you lose it did which
is what happened in the game and we just
moved few more and he's losing his roof
and also getting mated in few moves so
he resigned this was a very nice game
especially because this was a tournament
that I was hunting down with my
grandmaster norms I do think I got one
eye it's been five years but yeah this
is a very nice tournament for me I was
lower rated but it's all worked out very
well I can't but your rating and yeah
anyways so the lessons that I would like
for you to learn in this game is even if
you were even if your opponent isn't
falling into your preparation because my
opponent didn't 94 was kind of a weird
move I expected to cast oh sure it gets
a long castle and that kind of middle
game and in this game we didn't really
get the chance to be in the middle game
and everything got exchanged it off
pretty fast so even if the position you
don't get the position that you were
hoping for you should always be able to
find the best moves in that position and
just think what does your position need
so I think that's the biggest lesson
let's whoa I clicked on something wrong
so let's look at another game
so this was a game that I played with
deer on a Charlotte if I can get out of
this game sometime soon hopefully okay
so this is a game that I play it with on
a shower image and he goes championship
2018 I didn't have the best tournaments
that here but I had very nice games and
I really liked fighting again
so I usually play this against caro-kann
remember we saw a game last last week
that I played it against shark Raja and
or if you Polly Bishop f5 one of my
favorite lines is this one because the
ideas are quite simple you are gonna go
for two two bishops pretty viciously and
you cancel the place cuz I take it over
here so the only one of the ways for
black to fight this is with E 5 either
right now or whoops 97 then with the
idea in five so for example ninth of 45
because if you take then there is this
check and could take back with the Queen
and it's not exactly what Hawaiians
would hope for so white would want this
way more than that's a 5 so yeah but in
this specific game I prepared to play
this f3
my idea was kind of simple the the
theory is kind of um doesn't really
support this idea and I really haven't
played it much since I only played it in
people it's games but the idea is that
you just want to get as much space as
possible and for example the way she
played it in the game she played g6 and
I played c3 and Bishop for which I do
think sugar for wasn't the best idea
but after take take a five
now it gets a little interesting because
after Bishop if after the D takes e5
this was actually not blacks best
approach I do believe that there are
some a lot of dis ideas with Queen
coming out of be six that's are very
popular but sorry my chest misses being
a little slow
which I can't so sorry for inconvenience
but I can't close the tabs
I remind let's get back to the slow chat
space yay anyways so where was I oh
talking about c3 the indie game I just
wanted to develop my pieces and I
honestly wanted to confuse my opponents
which I did because they weren't
expecting me to play f3 and after E 5
DJC 5 I think the move that I was kind
of worried about was something like
Queen h4 because I can't really play
Bishop g3 and I probably should have
played something like g3 and for example
it's a clean goes back to e 7 it's kind
of unpleasant to look at just the pawn
structure the strong LightSquared black
Bishop
yeah so anyways after Queen takes d1
today we have to win games surprisingly
in the class after disses and games so
you'll be super high within games next
few hours so let me get you the
confidence class have to play against
and games
wow I'm just kidding
so what I want you to do in this
position is to find an idea about where
White's pieces belong one small hint if
it was white to move right now I would
definitely play Bishop c4 but I can't
because of Bishop e6 so yeah take a
second and think about where would you
want your pieces to be as white and as
black and what are the weaknesses in
your position as white and as black so I
think the first thing that should that
you should realize is that you're upon
up as whites
you can't cast oh and this is square
whoops this is square looks super yummy
so that's probably something that you
should work on you should try and put a
knight over here and those were the
things that I also noticed and I started
working on
so I played Knight f3 Knight whoops
sorry 92 and not my idea is I just want
to come here and place my Knights to d6
so in the game let's say you were whites
you play 92 your opponent plays h6 what
do you think your opponent is going for
well my thought my top thought process
Wow was that I want I realized my phone
is gonna start pushing these pawn so if
it goes blacks to move black would most
likely play g5 i with leadership g3 and
most likely g4 so one of the first
things that I thought about supposed to
play h4 but it's the problem with h4 in
my opinion was that this could become a
serious problem because this g4 square
would be super weak and there would be
no way for me to actually protect it and
it's a really nice outpost for blacks
night that's why I like this the idea of
h4 and also h3 well h3 it's still
possible but I felt like it doesn't
really serve much purpose because g4 is
is still possible
even if not g4m well black would simply
try and just do something like this
perhaps so that was my thought process
and so I kind of quickly decided to
ignore the idea of g5 for right now I
white knight c4 which is was a good move
but it's not the best move because the
best move is simply to play Bishop c4 if
it was me playing today I would have
seen this move right there
because realistically my f1 bishop is
worse than this ecigs bishop and
realistically my bishop is never gonna
be better than that bishop if my bishop
goes on c4 and the e8 Bishop e6 Fisher
goes anywhere else then yes this bishop
would be stronger because my bishop
would have won this war on who gets the
rights to this diagonal this hu g8 and
that is the only good diagonal on the
port so if it was me playing right now I
would have realized that my bishop on f1
this is never gonna be better than the
bishop on e6 and I would have killed to
exchange it off and after exchanging it
off now my knight can jump over here
attack this guy I could even think about
a six to open my f4 bishop up I would
have a lot of options basically and if
the opponents didn't take it let's say
97 or something now I can take it and
this is another week pawn that I could
potentially consider going after so my
actually one of my biggest mistakes in
this specific game was not playing
Bishop c4 now neither now or later so
I'll show you
I played 9 c4 I placed my knight into
this beautiful d6 square I developed my
King in hopes of bringing my rook closer
well the other thing was I wanted to
take on b7 but route b8 and then beat
you would fall so that's another little
thing to play king C to rook b8
protecting the pawn now what do you
think white should do little hands I
mentioned this move before so I should
have played Bishop c4 again even though
it's for the exchange enough and this
night would come backwards that's still
okay because first of all I would have
so much defenders for this week pawn
that g4 wouldn't matter and if you were
to push my night away I would just jump
back to d6 and now e6 is a serious
threat and all the same things that we
mentioned before
so if Bishop c4 is what I should have
played instead I played 94 seeing 94
looks like such a logical nice move
right you're going 94 you're attacking
this Bishop and you want to mess with
your opponent's pawn structures you want
to take two bishops this seems so nice
on the book right well not so much on
the board so the problem with Knight d4
is that I simply got two too many
attackers
on my pond and I lost this pawn so let's
say if I took over here and I played
Bishop c4 there's always this King g7
and protecting this pawn and there's no
direct way for me to continue attacking
be six I mean I could try to trick you
into maybe work at seven but would say
Rick if one you simply play Rick f8 and
that's the end of that story so what I
did in the game was I decided to just
give up the
spawn because there is no realistic way
for me to actually keep it and
now from what I remember I did not have
any more advantage on the game and even
though I have two bishops and they are
reat pawns and I have it strong 926 I
don't have an advantage so what I would
want you to think about is how to try
would you proceed what would be the move
that you would do as white and when
you're done thinking about that here's
some ideas for example if King is seven
I have this rookie of seven to take it
rook t1 nice huh so they've been so
pleasant if it happens going after a six
yeah alright so just something to think
about I did see this I did have this
idea to try and trick my opponents into
playing King g7 but it's too obvious and
she of course saw the idea of 94 to
block everything so well there is nuts
there here is for whites there isn't a
super strong move it's just about
realizing that you don't really have an
advantage anymore
and to try and find new ways to make
moves with that knowledge so what I did
was I just brought my knight back and I
tried to block this side a little more
and to try and ideally eat some pawns
now what do you think blacks should do
because black can actually simply just
take over here but what do you think he
should she should have done so what she
did was she point d5 again this is a
very honestly not much heat to it
disposition but you should always try
and create something and for me I tried
to create that something with for
example Rock f1 my idea was quite simple
if you are going to take this guy
I'll give this check King he aids I have
my service five if can create an average
route d1 and this would have been more
pleasant than my opponents not thinking
honestly because see it's a free piece
and it would have given me too many
chances to create compensation and to
create advantage possibilities so yeah
this is something that you should always
try to do for yourself to create
possibilities to create compensation and
to not let your opponents do it so my
opponent didn't let me do it she simply
plead her fate and I in this point I did
realize that I there's no way I can get
much out of this position and I simply
pretty much call this a day because we
exchanged everything off and after
reaching 30 we both agree to a draw
because this is it I mean you couldn't
have a more draw this chance game if you
even if you try it well exaggeration but
you understand the points
different-colored bishop same amount of
palms boring boring
so yeah that's another game that I
wanted to show you so I do want to talk
about the opening a little bit more
because one of the big ideas in this
game after they entered the end game was
this Bishop c4 which I continuously
missed and it cost me the point well
half a point so what I would want you to
try is to have that understanding that
okay so this Bishop doesn't really do
anything
this doesn't realistically seem to be
doing anything ever
so let's exchange it off with the good
bishop another way to think about it is
this Bishop is super active by probably
that most active piece in blacks
position so it is a good idea to
exchange it off it's always a good idea
to try an exchange of your opponent's
monster active pieces Oh about the
opening so f3 is very interesting and I
honestly don't remember why we chose to
play this against but I do remember that
I dis prepared and prepare it with my
den coach and I do remember working a
lot on g6 ideas and playing online a lot
on this because well honestly if you
were to play something like nine f6
right now I think one of the biggest
problems five-o what do you want to do
with the Knights rule 37 well I have
Bishop d3 and then maybe he seeks or
even a 6 whoops so there's a lot of a
lot of ideas to work on another thing
that's I remember I kind of was worried
about was this idea of
use if you take it there is this nasty
check or even taking here first and
Danny five because you if you take it
there is this check and these are a lot
of things to be cautious about so yeah
what I usually like to play now and
before this game - well anything except
this game was to play Knights teach you
and my ideas there is quite simple it's
Bishop a5 I just want to come after this
Bishop as mentioned slightly earlier in
the game doping so now black has a bunch
of ideas one of them is this Knight f6
and like Bishop here you push stirs take
or instead of Knight f6 g6 just bringing
the bishop out earlier so you're going
after this night so h5 doesn't really
it's not as interesting anymore and you
can't really to move the knight because
of the weakness of this night so
yeah these are some ideas that I'm gonna
try and show in the next next week
that's we're looking at more Carolyn and
Pierre and hopefully I'll be able to
show you more games not only in games
but yeah on how to try and play against
Pierre car welcome we've already seen
some French but I have more I always
have more French so don't worry about
that so yeah hopefully we'll get to wrap
those up in April French carro con
Pierre and modern modern is c6 first and
g6 d6 later that's kind of weird
fyodor those are some stuff that's with
white you should all be comfortable
knowing how to play and it's not that
hard to find
pleasant setup and then hopefully after
that we'll move to black openings and
sicilians
a 45 and there's so many openings to
cover so don't worry we have a lot to go
over well thank you for tuning in today
I wish I could see live chat and talk to
Mission one of you but I'll do my best
to look at the comments so please do
leave comments and I will I'll be live
on Thursday teaching something on Friday
on Saturday so tune in for those and
stay safe
you